hello and welcome to this video playing
Karen 84 already already the fifth game
against him got a ratty style it's not
technically ready eye-opening yet so he
wants to play Kings Indian attack it
seems yeah this is um a line that I like
for black it's very it's a quite
straightforward simple setup where you
have a good central control are you
playing for a draw here Karen huh
[Music]
I'm not making the draw but I mean
currently they store mother moved and
Bishop f5 and if I want to avoid it I
have to avoid it after night age form
yeah so yeah all the way back him it's
that way to do way to do it okay so if I
take this is going to take you 885 sorry
okay now how do we play this this one it
looks very odd oh come on come on I know
he can win points now in more than one
way but I think it yeah it's interesting
still to play so we can go Bishop d5 25
Bishop g5 but then I don't quite believe
I can do this one he also had Bishop g5
okay anyway now I wanted to go g4 but
maybe you know don't see anything better
relief
hmm so I have to have 694 or something I
don't know this is not the kind of
position where you go backwards
and 95 huh
no doesn't go them now
yeah f4 f4 is very it's like the least
subtle way I can take on d5 and take on
f4 actually tough I don't know what to
do really what is what's good here
294 Wow
okay I don't know I have to make a move
I think I'm taking one c4 is a threat
some sort of strategic threats like
taking and then efore and I thought this
this cannot be terrible for me at least
maybe maybe some c3 Queen Queen b3 m
this is some interesting this is
interesting
yeah I cannot play Queen b3 really
unfortunate yeah cannot prevent it
reading Jesus that keeps bad
yeah next game I should play less
creative that's usually the end of my
creative tries some bad position
ouch ouch oh wow Wow okay
the kind of session that you should have
stopped the game before okay wow that
was really bad I don't know what that
was I came yeah it's it's a bit tricky
here probably to avoid the draw but g5
was I can just play Knight except for
our distances this is just winning on
the spot of course
yeah that immediately wins from black of
course ng fibers of is bad in itself and
it's especially bad if you can play
Knight except for instead
I mean f1 looked kind of wrong to me but
didn't this I didn't see at all I mean I
just do to this to this so g5 takes
takes I mean I had some ideas Sam I was
thinking that I could get compensation
here but he didn't really care so I saw
this and I thought I have some play here
yeah with the 494 these kind of things
if I in fact it's kind of okay here this
thing and here I thought 94 I thought
okay look everyone I thought this idea
here could be interesting
he just went back and yeah now here I
need to indeed do something else I guess
Knight b6 is bad yeah exactly due to
taking n c3 I should go rook f8 with a
good position to look f8 preparing a
form now it makes it make some sense you
sometimes see the engine move and you
think okay why exactly is that a move
and the idea is to prepare a form I
couldn't do it immediately because of
Bishop d5 or GF whatever I actually
thought this that isn't actually that
clear I am but it didn't make sense it
just once you see it and you kind of mmm
okay and that friends a form and I'm
okay there it okay I saw this e3 idea
far too late and now I don't really have
a good choice
I mean a blunder - should be severed by
then the position was was already
completely lost and I'm falling below
2400 that's really a shame but I'm
playing badly last last games I'm just
playing badly so yeah yeah this is this
is already completely lost the thing is
said I mean if I could somehow
consolidate the position a little bit
then yeah with the space here you can
maybe play a little bit now still but I
just don't get any coordination yeah
he's got this quickly like all these
pieces I could have so there's no way to
hold it yeah I think the the problem
here is that um he he plays this f4 and
I have to refute it and otherwise it's
not that great for me I mean this is a
reputation and if if I don't see this
which it's not difficult actually but I
didn't then I don't really have
something great okay the engine gives a
5 or whatever he has some move but
that's not very human yeah you should
just take Knight affluent and this thing
is basically done with this position is
really bad yeah I mean I'm winning a
pawn and it's just a terrible setup the
dark squares are very weak so it's the
kind of thing that you have to exploit
if you want to win some games thanks a
lot for watching